let's talk now though about the actual
facts about Donald Trump's flip-flop on
this immigration issue we already talked
earlier in the show about Trump
spokeswoman Katrina Pearson dealing with
the Trump immigration flip-flop saying
he hasn't changed his position he's just
now using completely different words to
describe that position which apparently
hasn't changed here's the backstory on
the Trump immigration deportation
situation campaign started off with
deportation of all 11 million
undocumented immigrants being a hallmark
a key piece of the Donald Trump campaign
we are deporting them all we are
creating an immigration team which will
find and deport all 11 million
undocumented immigrants period last week
all of a sudden Donald Trump sort of
shifted tone saying well you know there
is sort of an opportunity here to figure
out a better way to do this and we're
really gonna focus on importing though
deporting not importing deporting those
who are actual up violent criminals and
I don't know blah blah blah blah blah
clearly a very significant change in
what he was planning to do the latest
now is uh he spoke at an Iowa rally and
he went back to the deport them idea but
he's still sort of using this word get
rid of the criminals but that it's all
going to happen within an hour when he
takes office but it's not necessarily
with a deportation force although how
else are you going to deport people
within an hour if you don't have some
kind of force to get them out of the
country none of it made sense it appears
to be reef lipping on an issue he
previously flip-flopped on already let's
take a look at the video from this Iowa
rally one day 1 i'm going to begin
swiftly removing criminal illegal
immigrants from this country
including removing the hundreds and
thousands of criminal illegal immigrants
that have been released into the United
States and United States communities
under the incompetent Obama Clinton
administration we're going to build a
great wall on the border and we're going
to institute nationwide avera fine stop
illegal immigrants from accessing
welfare and entitlements and develop an
egg exit entry you know what that is yes
it entry system to ensure those who
overstay their visas that they're
quickly by the way the woman to Trump's
right not even paying any attention to
what he's saying waving to people in the
crowd while Trump is talking about what
he's going to do so he's now using the
term we're going to deport criminal
illegal immigrants and this this is a
point of controversy because on the one
hand he may be referring to those who
have been convicted of non immigration
related crimes right that's the way some
people talk about who should be deported
but then there are the hardliners who
say no no just being here and being
undocumented is criminal and therefore
you should go so to be perfectly frank I
can't tell whether Trump has
flip-flopped once or twice on this issue
but he's definitely flip-flopped once
now in the meantime and this is where it
really gets interesting total confusion
with Trump's own co-manager of the
campaign Kellyanne Conway who is arguing
that Trump hasn't talked about deport
the deportation force since November she
went on Fox News Sunday with chris
wallace and said the following now the
deportation force i would like to
address that he hasn't mentioned that
since last november i think in a few of
the debates as you point out in his
convention speech last month he's
consistent on that now in terms of
addressing these many different areas of
a complex issue will he kind of
mentioned it this weekend on what planet
has Donald Trump not talked about forced
deportation since November unless Jason
this is a reference to self deportation
the only way in which Kellyanne Conway
is telling the truth here is if
on Trump is still planning on deporting
all 11 million undocumented immigrants
via self-deportation which he criticized
Mitt Romney for suggesting in 2012 at
this point I honestly don't know what
Trump's position is on undocumented
immigration but we know that none of it
makes any sense yeah I don't think she
knows where she is this point in the
campaign in the the platform that he/she
is standing for there just no no logic
no reason there and it essentially is a
campaign that stands for nothing and
that's really the point we've been
making for a very very long time which
is there really are no positions trumple
sort of say whatever comes to mind it's
also interesting that even bringing in
Kellyanne Conway has not gotten Trump
sort of on message in any way it truly
seems like no one can control him and
from that I sort of understand where the
conspiracy theories that he's really
only in this to help Hillary Clinton are
coming from I don't believe that his ego
would actually allow him to get into
this race with that goal up but his
actions are certainly suggestive of that
send me your thoughts on this i'm on
twitter at d pakman we will take a quick
break and be back with plenty more after
this warby parker is offering a free
five day home try-on to give you the
opportunity to check out their glasses i
personally wear warby parker glasses
when I'm not wearing my contact lenses
and I also started with one of these
free at home try ons of five pairs of
glasses you can get your free home
try-on and support the david pakman show
at Warby Parker trial dot-com / TDPS I
don't really like going into glasses
stores and trying on glasses while the
sales person sort of hovers over me and
I like more than 30 seconds to actually
figure out whether I like the glasses so
with the Warby Parker home try-on I was
able to pick five pairs that i liked put
them on in the comfort of my own home
pick the one I like the most and then
Warby Parker put my prescription lenses
in there for me a lot of people don't
know that the eyeglass industry is
controlled by just a few big
corporations that keep prices very high
like three hundred dollars for
prescription glasses high which is just
insane war be part
classes start at $95 that's what mine
cost and for every pair of glasses sold
Warby Parker distributes a pair of
glasses to someone in need you can try
five pairs and see what you like check
out the at-home trial and support our
show by going to Warby Parker dot-com /
TDPS it costs nothing